tv has given us some amazing characters
to follow over the years and not all of
them are good guys who are the most
memorable villains in television history
does a brat sitting on the iron throne
make the list what about a certain owner
of a fried chicken joint keep watching
everything about bbc's sherlock series
made it a fantastic modern reimagining
of arthur conan doyle's literary
detective classics benedict cumberbatch
and martin freeman did exactly as well
as you would expect as the titular
holmes and his assistant dr john watson
but the most fun character to watch here
might be holmes arch nemesis moriarty
played delightfully in the series by
andrew scott jim moriarty is supposedly
the world's only consulting criminal it
might be a position made specifically to
mock the consulting detective position
of his foil nemesis and obsession
sherlock holmes we wouldn't put it past
him he seemed to know he was playing a
part
every fairy tale needs a good
old-fashioned villain for his own
amusement he starts forcing holmes to
solve timed mysteries with the price of
failure being the execution of hostages
after revealing himself to sherlock in
one of the series best scenes he
continued toying with and torturing the
famed detective even going so far as to
steal the crown jewels just to draw him
out into the open we won't spoil the
ending of this legendary matchup because
if you haven't seen the series yet we
don't want to give you any excuse to
keep putting it off
based on the comic series of the same
name amazon primes the boys asks a
simple question what if superheroes were
real and owned by a major corporation
the answer is pretty ugly and wildly
entertaining the show's superman
stand-in played by anthony starr is
homelander he's a chisel jawed day saver
and an arrogant psychopathically violent
sadist who secretly despises the people
he's sworn to protect like most
sociopaths in real life he's capable of
hiding this disdain behind a handsome
grin money and power helped ensure that
a carefully crafted image of broadly
popular do-goodery is maintained but not
even that can hide the danger that lurks
behind those crystal blue eyes which can
turn into red lasers at any moment as
the show goes on we learn increasingly
disturbing details about homelanders
true origins the show is ongoing so it
remains to be seen what villainy he'll
get up to in future seasons
wow
that's
impressive
yes mr burns is a cartoon character but
nothing about this man is safe for
children like the obscenely wealthy
elite he hilariously satirizes burns is
completely out of touch with the lives
and experiences of the filthy peasants
surrounding his gated estate always
followed by doting manservant smithers
burns is so detached from reality that
he doesn't even bother pretending to
understand or care about others it's
rare to see the energy mogul without
that iconic evil grin and those steepled
fingers he throws his money and power
around without a care in the world using
both to do whatever he wants he acts
like he's above the law because as
evidenced by the fact that the
authorities refuse to go near the guy he
is
this court rules in favor of montgomery
burns
in one episode it's implied that burns
likely killed his own 11 siblings just
to position himself as the sole heir to
his family fortune in another we learned
that his mother is still alive at age
122 but that he doesn't speak to her
because she constantly belittles him and
had an affair with president taft in
another simpsons classic we learned
burns father was in the civil war that
he still has confederate slave holdings
in his investment portfolio and that he
likes to bribe local officials to get
what he wants we suppose none of this is
surprising
dexter might have ended on a rough note
at least before its 2021 revival but at
its peak it was must watch prestige
television based on the 2004 novel
darkly dreaming dexter by jeff lindsey
the story follows the titular dexter
morgan played by michael c hall he's a
forensic tech who works for the police
in miami analyzing blood patterns at
crime scenes however when nobody's
looking he's also a serial killer who
targets murderers who are either let off
on technicalities or otherwise
insufficiently punished in season 4 we
meet arthur mitchell like most john
lithgow characters arthur seems like an
upstanding tax paying family man he's
the last person on earth you'd expect to
be a serial killer with three decades of
experience under his blood-stained belt
that's exactly what makes a bubbly
impossible to dislike actor like john
lithgow such a perfect casting choice it
turns out that arthur aka the trinity
killer so named because he murders in
sets of threes bases his killings on his
defining childhood trauma we won't go
into all the gory details here but both
the method and the victim of each murder
are patterned after his ill-fated family
members even more all of these family
members suffered gruesome deaths
indirectly traceable to an accident he
caused when he was 10. it's tragic
horrific stuff but that and the mystery
surrounding the crimes that leads to
thrilling manhunts is exactly why the
character represents dexter at its
horrifying best
most great villains inspire anger fear
and revenge fantasies the borg a
parasitic cybernetic alien race in the
star trek universe inspire despair and
hopelessness that's a chilling but
effective place to start if surrender is
the go-to option you know you're dealing
with a truly frightening baddie in one
sense this is an entire alien
civilization so putting them on here is
almost like including all nazis or the
empire from star wars but star trek the
next generation fans know that while the
borg can assume the appearance of any
creature it's actually a single organism
known as a hive mind it's not an unheard
of science fiction concept rick and
morty's unity and beta-7 characters
spring to mind as well as the flood from
halo but it's rarely if ever been done
quite this well in the star trek
universe the process by which the
collective assimilates its innumerable
victims is technological rather than
biological nanoprobes are perhaps a
little less unnervingly frightening than
slimy tentacles invading your face holes
and wrapping themselves around your
brain however when you realize the borg
also assimilates uses and learns from
the technologies of its captive
constituent drones you realize that the
borg are a major threat that even the
crew of the enterprise can't handle on
its own
even with multiple emmy awards and near
universal critical acclaim one can argue
that hbo's deadwood set in a late 19th
century western mining town in south
dakota is still one of the most slept on
tv shows in recent memory the show
helmed by david milch features a mix of
fictional and historical elements and
follows the titular community's ascent
from a frontier camp to a thriving
little town the characters are great too
even if they're fictionalized versions
of actual figures like seth bullock
calamity jane wild bill hickok and wyatt
earp everyone brings their a-game
throughout the series but ian mcshane's
al suarengin
pimp gangster is the slick glass of
chilled bourbon you're really looking
forward to when you sit down for an
episode
all right then
we're not quite sure how mcshane pulls
off making such a reprehensible person
so oddly charming and enviably cool but
he does he makes an absolute meal out of
every line sneer sip and trigger pull
but like all great villains he was never
flat or one note as rolling stone points
out the bar owning mobster might exploit
the titular town but he'll be damned if
he lets any other crooked politician or
oil baron get their claws anywhere near
it just don't mistake that for altruism
we're positive that's only because he's
invested so much time and energy
positioning himself in the center of the
town's institutions and wants to
fiercely protect his investment
regardless swearingen is not someone you
want to mess with as evidenced in the
infamous finale the powers that be
didn't know exactly how to end smash hit
mid 2000's drama lost but man was it a
wild ride getting to that point the
story follows the de facto leader jack
shepard sawyer hurley kate and the other
marooned survivors of doomed oceanic
airlines flight 815 at the beginning of
the show the plane crashes in the
pacific ocean between sydney and los
angeles kicking off the story you could
make the argument that hunger thirst
disease exposure exotic creatures
interpersonal conflict madness and
depression are the survivor's main
antagonists still series creator jj
abrams and the other creative leads
didn't want to go the predictable route
with this one instead they filled the
island with mysteries that kept viewers
hooked for years arguably the most
compelling of these mysteries was the
others the mysterious denizens of the
island and one member stood out from the
others benjamin linus the monstrously
violent methods linus employs to protect
the island's secrets are chillingly
offset by the character's awkward
neurotic cagey mannerisms but actor
michael emerson did such an amazing job
that by the end of the show the
character was a fan favorite who got his
own redemption arc
you could make the argument that every
major character on hbo's game changing
late 90s early 2000s award magnet mega
hit the sopranos is a villain these are
after all murderous backstabbing
mobsters we're dealing with but this
ugly rose simply must go to livia
soprano played by the brilliant nancy
marchand until her tragic passing in
2000 livia is a cruel vindictive
unloving mother to mafia dawn's son tony
soprano she even tries to have him
killed at one point while that
contributes to her placement on this
list it's only a part of the larger
picture a hard upbringing and a rough
marriage to johnny soprano ultimately
forged her into a vicious
passive-aggressive nightmare that
everyone should fear becoming in their
old age she generally leaves the
shooting and killing to tony and those
he surrounds himself with however she
knows how to wield words like knives
spreading lies and rumors to anyone and
everyone around her simply to disrupt
their lives in relationships even to the
point of violence it truly does seem
like she only delights in dragging
everyone down into the depths of utter
joylessness with her
i know when i'm not wanted
less than stellar final season aside
game of thrones gave us several years of
peerless prestige television as any fan
of the show or george rr martin's books
knows there were plenty of villains
lurking in westeros and beyond there
were tywin and cersei lannister as well
as jaime at least before his redemption
arc there was the night king who might
have made this list if it weren't for
his insultingly anti-climactic demise
there's the mountain 2 and melisandre
and peter littlefinger baelish as well
as countless other minor characters
ramsay bolton a monstrous sadist who
briefly rules winterfell gets an
honorable mention here too but the king
of scoundrel's award ultimately goes to
joffrey baratheon that's truly saying
something if you think about it most of
those other baddies were ruthless
killers conquerors and torturers joffrey
who briefly rules the seven kingdoms
following the death of robert baratheon
is a snot nosed brat he does have
moments of violence like ordering ned
stark's beheading and torturing and
killing some women in his chambers but
for the most part jack gleason's
character makes the list for simply
being an utterly loathsome kid he's more
fun to hate than most villains on tv
if we're being honest plot armor may
have played a bigger role in walter
white's victory over gustavo fring than
we'd like to admit that's not to say the
steps leading to the iconic moment in
which the chilean restaurateur
international meth kingpin has his face
blown off by a wheelchair bomb weren't
fought for and well earned but gus
spring played by the chilling and
terrific giancarlo esposito was waltz
better in nearly every way he wasn't
much of a chemist but he was every bit
as brilliant as his top cook if not more
so he didn't have any of walt's baggage
either no terminal cancer diagnosis no
family situation that was on the brink
of collapse at any given moment no
family in the dea gus knew the players
and the game like nobody's business
before he foolishly let heisenberg into
his operation he had something walt
never enjoyed stability it was all
planned out well oiled and running like
clockwork it took everything walt and
jesse had to get the drop on friend who
spent much of the series 10 steps ahead
of every threat our two meth cooking
protagonists included
the wire which examines the
self-sustaining wheel of rot and
corruption in early 2000's baltimore as
the larger condemnation of society
itself is one of the finest pieces of
television ever produced it's got no
shortage of timeless villains it has
stan valchek and bill rawls two
cutthroat high-ranking cops who stop at
nothing to climb up the ladder then
there are stringer bell and avon
barksdale two old school gangsters who
run a heroine slinging op in the city's
projects there's maury levy a sleazy but
seasoned lawyer who represents the top
dogs in the city's criminal underworld
even our heroes make enough questionable
choices throughout the show that it's
hard calling them that but the most
chilling character on the show and
possibly any show is marlo stanfield
young hungry gangbangers who seek the
crown of being the most feared name on
the corners are nothing new in the world
of the wire what sets marlow apart is
the sociopathic methods he and his
subordinates chris partlow and snoop
employ to get ahead before long far more
experienced and established players are
either dead imprisoned or cowering in
fear perhaps their greater experience
itself was their downfall they were so
set in their ways that by the time they
realized this violent newcomer couldn't
be contained with the usual methods it
was too late
pawns man in the game
they get capped quick
the cigarette smoking man is more of a
foreboding presence in the early seasons
of the x-files but the brooding face of
the mysterious syndicate eventually
becomes the primary antagonist of the
supernatural series even after the
syndicate is destroyed he remains always
scheming to thwart mulder and scully's
plans to reveal the existence of aliens
to the world so he can soften up the
planet for extraterrestrial invasion it
sounds a little bit goofy if you've
never seen the show but actor william b
davis turned the character into a
chilling embodiment of a shadowy
government operative working in unseen
angle even as the show lumbers on and
more about the cigarette smoking man is
necessarily revealed his true
motivations and capabilities remain
shrouded mulder and scully only seem to
know that he's up to no good trying to
lay out the red carpet for aliens for
reasons he's reluctant to reveal why
questions irrelevant
played by larry hagman in all
357 episodes of dallas jr ewing's
villainous scheming almost makes him
sound like a maniacally laughing cartoon
after all the amoral oil baron spends
much of the show's original run doing
the villainous things you'd expect him
to be doing the series made it clear
that jr is such a ruthless overachiever
because he never got enough love from
mom and dad who showered his brothers
with affection instead from birth he had
to fight for what he felt was his only
achieving corporate control after a
stint in vietnam and after his brothers
went their own ways in life by that
point jr was thoroughly set in the
conniving psychopathic ways that have
made him such a fixture for so many
decades but ewing wouldn't have been the
icon he is on a show that ran for this
long if he were the flat one-note
character suggested by his reputation
the show sprinkles in just enough
tenderness and vulnerability regarding
his family that when he's betrayed or
fails you catch yourself empathizing
with a man who almost never empathizes
with others it's a testament to hagman's
stellar stable performance as one of tv
history's best characters
just like in the harrison ford movie you
might be more familiar with the fugitive
tv show follows dr richard kimball
played by david jansen who's on the run
from police detective lieutenant philip
gerard he's also seeking the truth after
being wrongfully accused of murdering
his wife all he knows about the real
killer is that the man had one arm and
supposedly likes to bludgeon his victims
perhaps the best part about the
one-armed man played by bill reich is
how little we see hear or know about him
for the first three seasons he can
hardly be called a character at all he's
only in a handful of episodes 10 total
by the time the show wrapped up in 1967
he serves primarily as a foreboding
presence and a goal for kimball like his
hunter the one armed man takes odd jobs
and assumes various false identities
while fleeing or hiding however he has
one advantage kimball doesn't the police
are on his side whenever he gets a tip
as to kimball's whereabouts destination
or next goal he makes sure to hand it to
the authorities in the hopes they'll
arrest the doctor it's a testament to
reish's performance and a stellar
writing staff that a character so rarely
seen could be such an effective big bad
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you